professor gertrud höhler sie hat ein
buch geschrieben über kanzlerin merkel
das zu einem vernichtenden urteil kommt
angela merkel arbeitet am zerfall der
demokratie darüber sollten wir reden
herzlich willkommen zum dialog
dankeschön
und hier haben wir das buch um das es
geht die party wie angela merkel
deutschland umbaut und zur verstärkung
hinten angela merkel in derselben pose
wie mafia boss marlon brando im film der
pate
was frau köhler bringt sie auf die idee
angela merkel im zusammenhang mit der
mafia zu bringen es gibt wenn ich mit
meinen wissenschaftlichen kollegen
sprechen soll eine strukturelle analogie
es ist einmal das schweigen ein
autoritäres schweigen wie ich es
definiere
es ist gleichzeitig eine unideologische
art des auftritts das ist unglaublich
wichtig denn wir haben nicht eigentlich
ein merkelsches bekenntnis ein
merkelsches credo gibt sich und
gleichzeitig das einsickern von
illegalen handlungen in das legale
system mit dem wir leben das sie drei
ganz wichtige merkmale die man
beschreiben muss wenn man geheimbünde
beschreibt insgesamt fahren sie ja
ziemlich scharfes geschütz auf ich
dachte einmal zitieren sie sagen ein
staatsstreich droht sie sagen eu
verträge missachtet sie genauso wie das
grundgesetz und angela merkel arbeitet
am zerfall der demokratie das haben wir
ja schon zitiert wie kommen sie auf die
idee also der staat sprich das ist meine
definition für das was sie gemacht hat
mit der sogenannten energiewende
der start der energiewende wenn er nicht
regierungsamtlich wäre müsste als
staatsstreich bezeichnet werden weil ein
ganzer haufen von gesetzen vom tisch
gefegt wurde
darunter sind garantien die wir in der
verfassung sehen eigentumsrechte das
aktienrecht das heißt es ist hier ein
eingriff passiert für den wir keine
parallele haben in unserer geschichte
seit dem zweiten weltkrieg
und das von einer person ohne absprache
mit den nachbarländern und schon gar
unter einer verspäteten einbeziehung des
parlaments die wir ja auch in der
sogenannten euro- rettung immer häufiger
haben im grunde
parlament als zuschauer schauen wir uns
mal diese energiewende ein bisschen
genauer an
weil das ist ja für sie auch immer
wieder der beleg dafür dass angela
merkel keine werte hat sie sagen angela
merkel benutzt die werte als
manövriermasse können sie ein bisschen
erläuterte sie dass man sie benutzt
werte wenn sie den eindruck hat ihren
mitspielern die ja traditioneller
verwurzelt sind als sie müsste das jetzt
die zustimmung abringen beispiel bei der
energiewende drei monate nach fukushima
hat sie ja ein bekenntnis abgelegtes
sehr untypisch für sie ist das
wahrscheinlich ein berater ergebnis war
sie hat nämlich gesagt also jetzt habe
ich das auf mich wirken lassen
für mich hat sich etwas verändert für
milch angela die herren
das bedeutet sie sagt im grunde der
staat das bin ich und jetzt kommt die
folgerung mit die folgerung lautete wir
lassen die ethikkommission entscheiden
ob die reaktoren also hochtechnologie
atomtechnologie hier weiter laufen
sollten unter töpfer war dienstbar und
hat das buchstäblich gemacht und hat
dann gesagt wenn festgestellt sollen
nicht mehr weiterlaufen
das ist ein ein gebrauch von werten der
nicht nur situativ unbehagen weg sondern
der auch rein instrumental die werte
einsetzt weil die anderen mitspieler
dann eher zu gewinnen sind für eine
handlung einverstanden die energiewende
kam er schon recht plötzlich möchte
trotzdem die gegenthese aufstellen
die atomenergie ist ja kein wert an sich
sondern nur ein mittel zum zweck und
gerade mit der energiewende könnte man
ja sagen hatte angela merkel gemäß ihrem
amtseid gehandelt sie hat schaden vom
deutschen volk abgewendet weil sie uns
aus einer gefährlichen technologie führt
ja was ja nicht ganz richtig ist denn
der vergleich mit fukushima ist einer
und heute wissen wir es auch aus japan
amtlich ist einer der so nicht zutrifft
wir haben keine art
um werke am meer in erdbebengebieten mit
tsunami gefährdung wir haben keine
schlampige wartung unserer
atomkraftwerke gehabt und wir haben
gleichzeitig eben eine technologie die
der japanischen nur ähnlich ist aber im
ganzen überlegen ist so aber wo jetzt ja
aber schauen sie mal wenn sie wenn sie
sagen sie hat hier was abgeräumt was
fällig war da müssen wir noch sagen es
gab ein gesetz von der grün roten
regierung beschlossen das einen
geordneten rückzug ohne die
unglaublichen auch ökonomischen schäden
die wir jetzt durch diesen plötzlichen
umsturz asien rück zu haben
es gab dieses gesetz auch das gesetz
wurde gekippt und man fragt sich warum
um die grünen rein zu holen damit wir
nicht weiter so mächtig bin diese waren
um die gedanken von einer
baden-württemberg-wahl abzulenken
lappalien verglichen mit dem was er
jetzt haben mit der sogenannten
energiewende wo ein minister
ausgewechselt wurde der einsatz kenner
war ersetzt durch ein amateur
einen dilettanten der jetzt immer viele
sehen also im fall wir haben das nicht
tun ob herr altmaier mein fall ist herr
altmaier es bestimmt nicht als
spezieller kenner der materie mit der
jetzt befasst ist und das war auch nicht
erwünscht weil man wusste und auch
merkel wusste und weiß läuft schlecht
mit der energiewende
das heißt wir haben schachzüge wir haben
gleichzeitig wenig rücksicht auf die
übrigen beteiligten und wenn sie sagen
amtszeit und schaden abwenden da muss
ich ihnen sagen der schaden der jetzt
auf die deutsche bevölkerung zukommt mit
den hohen strompreisen vor allem auf die
nicht so leistungsfähigen bürger ist ja
wie denn in diesem amt zeit
unterzubringen aber sagen sie denn allen
ernstes angela merkel hätte an der
kernenergie festhalten sollen nach
fukushima nach dem 80 prozent der
deutschen gegen diese energieformen sind
eher das kommt ja darauf an wie man
führt wenn man sagt bei uns genauso
gefährlich wie drüben und die deutschen
bürger hab keine lust nachzudenken ob
das stimmt und die ökonomen die uns
sagen können dass es anders ist in die
atomphysiker die uns das sagen können
sind nicht schnell
warum weil sie zum teil eigene
interessen hüten und sich sagen na ja
wir brauchen ja wieder subventionen vor
allem jetzt wo wir dann noch mit
auflagen belegt sind die ja erst über
ein jahr nach dieser neuen maßnahme dann
vom tisch kam aber anfangs ist es das
zahlt ihr alles weiter als ob ihre
atommeiler weiterlaufen bis der abgaben
zahlen
die damit zu tun haben dass ihr
atomenergie liefert also man muss doch
abgesehen von dem gesetz dass grün-rot
mit viel augenmaß gemacht hat muss man
doch fragen wo ist der schaden größer
wenn wir mitten in einer schweren krise
in europa sind und mannschaft zusätzlich
eine geld verbrennungsmaschine wie diese
energiewende
dann ist es nicht besonders
verantwortungsvoll gehandelt das war ein
beispiel dass sie anführen die
energiewende ich würde gerne auf einen
zweiten punkt kommt sie sagen parteien
und parlamente werden entmachtet ich
zitiere sie
sie sprechen von einem lautlosen umsturz
in richtung all parteien regierung was
meinen sie damit also angela merkel hat
ja schon in der großen koalition
begonnen themen abzusaugen ich sage zu
enteignen oder zu entleihen idee im
leasing kann man das auch nennen aus zum
beispiel ihrem damaligen
koalitionspartner portfolio da hat sie
sozialdemokratische kernangebot
rausgenommen und hat auf die weise nicht
nur für einen geschwächten austritt aus
dieser koalition bei der spd gesorgt
sondern zunächst auch für eine
unklarheit wo es eigentlich die grenze
zwischen diesen beiden parteien die
klassischerweise immer gewetteifert
haben und es bedeutet ein politischer
wettbewerb ist gewollt in der demokratie
und der wird gelähmt wenn man aus allen
parteien die kernstücke raus nimmt und
sie sich aneignet so dass der bürger
sich sagt jetzt weiß ich gar nicht mehr
was ich wählen soll
gegenrede es gehört auch zur demokratie
dass parteien ihre position auch mal
revidieren da wo die position nicht mehr
zu halten sind also bei der union
die kämpft jetzt endlich auch für
kitaplätze
die hält nicht mehr am leitbild der frau
am herd fest die hat ihren frieden mit
der homo-ehe gemacht das sind doch
längst notwendige positionsveränderungen
ohne die die cdu untergegangen wäre also
ich fange mal bei den kita-plätzen an
wenn sie einjährige kinder in die
gruppen verwahrung schicken dann ist das
nicht nur ein sozialistisches angebot
sondern dann ist das gegen alle
forschung die wir haben keine gute tat
gegenüber diesen kindern
dies wissen viele in der cdu es wissen
auch viele in der spd und alle meinen
der trend ist ebenso wir müssen da
mitmachen
ich kenne so viel forschung zum kleinst
kind alter das ich da mal bleibe wie
alle fachleute die sich damit befassen
wie alle kinderärzte dass ich dabei
bleibe zu sagen das ist ein schaden wenn
wir ein kind mit einem jahr in seiner
entwicklung von bindungen von vertrauen
von liebesbeziehungen in dieser weise in
eine störung schicken wie so eine gruppe
ist das kind ist zu klein dafür so und
darum ist diese ganze kita nummer an der
stelle wo sie die einjährigen und die
zweijährigen erfassen will eben ein
schwerer fehler ja durchaus eine
veränderung in unserem menschenbild und
da muss man eigentlich widerstand
leisten und das ist nicht die frau am
herd die diesen widerstand leistet
sondern das ist die aufgeklärte medizin
die seit jahrzehnten erfolglos in die
arena ruft leute macht das nicht die
kinder verlieren grundvertrauen die
kinder werden sozial schwächer als
andere die in einer liebes bindung
aufgewachsen sind
also das ist ja ihr gutes recht in
sachen kita plätze und betreuung des 13
jährigen die andere ansicht der andere
an sich zu haben als angela merkel
aber das ist doch noch kein beleg dafür
dass angela merkel einen unzulässigen
ideenklau
macht ich zitiert einmal ursula von der
leyen die hat gesagt merkel ist
wandlungsfähig in die zukunft hinein
anders ausgedrückt die angela merkel
modernisiert die ja cdu es ist die wohl
träumt eben positionen auf die nicht
mehr zu halten sind ja das ist die frage
wenn man das definiert was man dabei an
führung investiert also positionen die
nicht mehr zu erhalten sind ist auch ein
schöner ausdruck weil er passt wenn man
nicht klar macht was für ein
menschenbild man hat wenn man nicht klar
macht dass es unverlierbare im
haltepunkte für menschen gibt zum
beispiel sich aufeinander verlassen
können versprechen halten
frau merkel sagt gibt keine versprechen
dann wirst du erpressbar
das ist das was mir nicht zuerst zu
versprechen ein feld ein versprechen
bindet ja stimmt das heißt wir müssen
uns aufeinander verlassen
bei merkel ist dieses weg gleiten von
verbindlichkeiten die zum teil in unsere
verfassung verankert sind da steht nicht
die frau am herd
aber da stehen entfaltung shrek
unterstehen im bildungs rechte die die
menschen haben auch wenn sie noch klein
sind das heißt dieses wegrutschen von
verbindlichkeiten die in jeder kultur
auch in archaischen menschen
gemeinschaften eine große rolle spielen
ich erkenne die menschen die zu mir
gehören und ich lerne mit ihnen
sozialverträglich umzugehen
das heißt nicht alles was im moment
wegschwimmt zum beispiel auch die
wettbewerb in der politik über den wir
eben gesprochen haben aber auch der
wettbewerb in der wirtschaft wenn ich
die energie verstaatliche das schöne
menge weg also alles was wegschwimmt ist
nicht deshalb zum wegschwimmen gemacht
weil es zugelassen wird
aber verlangen sie von der cdu
vorsitzenden und der kanzlerin angela
merkel nicht etwas was automatisch zum
untergang der union führen würde dass
sie in punkten wo die alte cdu-position
hemmungslose in der minderheit ist bei
der kernenergie oder bei den
kita-plätzen dass sie auf diese position
hat obwohl jeder weiß damit verliert sie
den nächst war das kann doch nicht sinn
einer partei führerin sei also bei den
kita-plätzen finde ich das problem so
ernst dass ich in der tat sagen würde es
lohnt sich zu erklären was fast alle
eltern wissen nur ehrgeizige eltern
nicht zu sagen sich trauen was kleine
kinder brauchen warum haben wir immer
weniger kinder in deutschland weil die
erwachsenen eine position einnehmen die
wie eine konkurrenz zum kinder leben ist
und ob das so bleibt und ob wir dann
diese rentendiskussion haben die wir
jetzt haben das spielt auch eine rolle
für führungs botschaften und wenn die
führungs botschaft nicht da sind dann
sagen sich die leute naja das ist hierzu
nicht muss aufpassen ich bin mit meiner
meinung in der minder durchsage noch was
zur cdu die cdu hat in einer langen
kette von landtagswahlen immer weiter
verloren
also es ist nicht die partei die
entsprechend den hohen werten der chefin
in einem in einer aufsteigenden linie
unterwegs ist warum hat sie eine geringe
akzeptanz des virus kann cdu buch
sondern ein buch über das ganze system
in dem wir leben
wenn wir dann immer mehr entscheidungen
haben wo es leute wenn jetzt jemand
abweichen stimmt dann ist das gegen
europa es könnte aber sein dass der
vernünftige gedanken für eine andere
lösung der euro-krise hat er darf sie
noch nicht mal mehr zusammenhängend
äußern er darf nur noch zettel abgeben
im parlament das parlament wird von der
exekutive an den rand getrennt die
exekutive entscheidet und das parlament
ist eine art beobachtergruppe alles
dieses beschreibe ich ja wenn sie dann
fragen warum hören wir dass sich
deutlicher mit der faust in der tasche
es ist eine widmung von dem buch für
alle die die faust in der tasche haben
und ich kenne eine menge cdu leute die
mir genau dieses sagen und wenn dann
frau von der leyen in einer debatte mit
mir in den raum rufnamen dann kann ich
nur sagen meint sie das wirklich ernst
die leute verraten
die verlieren ihren job wenn ich die
frau hatte
sie haben ja jetzt schon übergeleitet
zum nächsten großen thema das uns diese
tage alle beschäftigte euro und euro
krise und auch hier sagen sie angela
merkels regierungsstil führt dazu dass
normen und gesetze gebrochen werden
können sie das erklären
es ist im zuge der finanztransaktionen
viel europäisches recht gebrochen worden
das weiß jeder der dabei ist und es wird
argumentiert ja wir hatten keine zeit
die langsamen abstimmungsprozesse zu
durchlaufen um die gesetze zu ändern
frau merkel bringt das thema jetzt
erneut auf den tisch sie sagt alle statt
gesetze der eu wollen wir jetzt ändern
das dauert jahre
wir wissen dass wir die jahre nicht
haben sodann wird argumentiert ja weil
das alles so eilig ist brechen wir jetzt
mal recht
und wenn sie sich einen ehemaligen
verfassungsrichter anhören wie herrn
kirchhof der sagt dann kann das wirklich
sein dass wir rechtssicherheit in europa
opfern um ja was denn eine nicht
erreichbare vermeintliche
finanzsicherheit herzustellen sind das
werte die wir gegeneinander aufrechnen
kann einverstanden
der vertrag von maastricht wird von vorn
bis hinten gebrochen doch stehe diese
sogenannte no-bailout-klausel drin ein
staat ist nicht für die staatsschulden
eines anderen staates schuldig und
vielleicht das verfassungsgericht wird
darüber urteilen ist auch der esm
wm-siebte nicht verfassungs
verfassungsgemäß aber wenn sie das alles
im ernst angela merkel vorwerfen angela
merkel ist doch im prinzip die letzte
kämpfer die sich noch gegen die schulden
union stimmt in einem europa wo die
schuldenstaaten die mehrheit es ist dass
die nächste rote linie und die anderen
roten linien haben wir alles schon
hinter uns und immer hat es geheißen
ohne uns das machen wir nicht
herr weidmann ist jetzt allein auf
weiter flur mit seiner festen
überzeugung dass die ezb nicht tun darf
die europäische zentralbank nicht tun
darf was sie zu tun im begriff ist
merkel hat immer wieder aber nicht
besonders laut und nicht besonders
herrisch geltend gemacht dass wir
eigentlich das nicht wollen und das
nicht wollen wir wollen eine fiskalunion
also dass die leute zum sparen gezwungen
werden
was natürlich faktisch gar nicht möglich
ist das werden wir erleben das heißt sie
ist alle schritte mit gegangen während
sie durch ihren status als königin
europas warum ist sie das geworden weil
sie das stärkste land regiert sie könnte
meier müller schulz heißen männlich sein
ganz egal jeder hätte diesen titel weil
das land so stark ist das heißt sie hat
diesen status und die deutschen und
natürlich die nehmerländer wenn ich die
masse nennen da auf die
hochverschuldeten die von uns mittel
haben wollen weil die sagen du kannst
den königstitel wenn du weiter liefern
wir müssen es wirklich auch mal so
verstehen wer das heißt merkel ist nicht
die texte merkel hat nicht viel
veranlassen können könnte man jetzt
sagen
gegen diesen abläufen bei vermisse ich
sage wenn sie das stärkste land in
europa regiert das am meisten ausblutet
in der sogenannten euro-rettung und wir
werden erleben
ob es am ende überhaupt fruchtet ob die
zeit reicht die wir haben nur durch geld
das zu ersetzen was es strukturen
passieren müsste was wir als helfer bei
aufbauleistungen angefangen von
griechenland in diesen ländern bringen
müssten
wir werden sehen was dabei rauskommt
aber immer wäre der chef von deutschland
am schärfsten in der kritik warum wir
könnten uns doch ein votum leisten wie
es herr weidmann jetzt allein vertritt
das heißt dass tatsächlich banken nicht
dafür zuständig sind länder mit geld zur
verliebt belli von banken mit geld zu
beliefern
wann kommen wir da wieder raus und
stellen sich nur mal vor ein deutscher
regierungschef und eine deutsche
regierungschefin würde diese position
glaubwürdig vertreten gleichzeitig
abgesandte mit ökonomischen juristischem
sachverstand in die verschuldeten länder
schicken weil ja korruption auch eine
verirrung im regelwerk es im spiel
regelwerk mit dem wir unterwegs sind und
weil der rückweg mindestens solange es
wieder hin weg wenn uns das klang nach
dann wissen wir es dauert alles viel zu
lange wir müssen andere maßnahmen
ergreifen
und wenn ich hier sage könnte dass nicht
deutschland sein könnte das nicht sein
dass das stärkste land sagt vorne
wir gehen mit etwas anderem vor an nicht
nur mit dem gefüllten geldsack sondern
mit strukturhilfen mit den hilfen den
handel wieder in gang zu bringen und das
heißt wo möglich auch mit beweglichkeit
was den wert und die neben flexibilität
der währung angeht wenn wahrscheinlich
werden wir das brauchen wir haben eine
starke währung die passt zu vielen
ländern gar nicht in europa verstehen
sie warum haben wir nicht da die
führungsrolle
warum wird uns viele weltweit
vorgeworfen dass wir streberhaft
unterwegs sind
ich glaube wir könnten unsere
ökonomische stärke besser ausnutzen als
wir das tun also ein energisches
plädoyer für eine andere europapolitik
ich möchte noch auf einen anderen
vorwurf in richtung merkel kommen
sie sagen die starken gehen sie mordet
alle diejenigen die ihr als potenzielle
konkurrenten gefährlich gefährlich
werden könnten
auch hier wird die gegenthese guttenberg
wolf althaus röttgen sind die nicht alle
über sich selbst gestürzt
aber vergessen sie doch bitte nicht wie
zum beispiel der abschied von herrn
guttenberg vor sich ging also da hat ja
doch merkel eine entscheidende grund
position geäußert die die akademische
jugend auf die barrikaden getrieben hat
und niemand hat die dahw persönlich
wieder runter geholt die haben einfach
irgendwann aufgegeben
wenn man sagt ich habe den doch nicht
als wissenschaftlichen assistenten
engagiert ich haben eben doch nur und er
ist hervorragend als
verteidigungsminister
doch er zu lange gehalten und nicht
gestürzt er hätte doch vorher schon von
den socken bei der ich in der gutenberg
geschichte interessiert mich nur dass
mit welcher begründung sie ihn halten
wollte weil diese begründung ist eine
botschaft dass man sagt leute der kann
betrüger auf irgendeinem gebiet seien
aber auf dem gebiet hab ich mir gar
nicht eingestellt es kommt dazu
er war jahns ist ein csu-mann das heißt
hatte ja nicht die volle verantwortung
dafür dass der ins kabinett kam weil es
übung dass man die minister akzeptiert
die den koalitionspartner bringt und
hier bündnis vater bringt aber es geht
darum wie ich damit umgehen eine
verfehlung da ist was für eine botschaft
dass in meine gemeinschaft von bürgern
brennt und die anderen fälle die sie
nennen wie war das denn mit der wahl von
herrn wolf das war doch eine taktische
maßnahme unter ausschluss ganz bestimmte
mitglieder der bundesversammlung so wie
schon im fall kührer köhler wollte sie
haben weil köhler ein fremdling war in
der in deutschland und weil sie wussten
kann ich steuern sie hat ihn besteuert
diese geschichte ist geschrieben lese
jan heitmann von der süddeutschen er das
2006 schon geschrieben 2006 prophetisch
beschrieben wie er entmachtet wird wir
gesteuert wird und dann hat er eines
tages aufgegeben auch hier war die wahl
partiell manipuliert weil wohl phase
noch stärker manipuliert das war der
letzte rivale der wurde ruhig gestellten
präsidentenamt so und dann waren da eben
leider sehr eifrige zeitungsleute und
die geschichte läuft ja heute noch nun
entzweit er sich vor gericht mit seinem
sehr mäßigen zwilling wie er ihn immer
nannte sein sprecher
das heißt wir haben doch hier
manipulierte wahlen die tatsächlich und
das ist für uns demokraten eigentlich
eine belüftung dazu führen dass es nicht
klappt den kandidaten die man taktisch
rein schiebt weil man sie benutzen will
so und der gauck war der bildfläche
schon bei wahl nummer zwei da war er
nicht durchsetzbar und bei der dritten
wahl hat sie auch gesagt er ist in der
cdu nicht wählbar
was glauben sie wie viele fäuste in den
taschen als sie das gesagt hat und dann
hat sie den racheakt der kleinen gelben
der liberalen bekommen und die haben
gesagt wir haben zuzulassen
herr gauck soll das werden und dann
stand nachher ende merkel hörigen presse
muss ich schon sagen da stand dann drin
dass der vorschlag von frau merkel
gewesen dass herr glaub das wird
verstehen sie es sind kleine kleine
korrupte geschichte
und da sage ich wollen wir so
weitermachen wollen wir im namen der
rettung europas zum beispiel auch so
weiter machen dass wir sagen ethik moral
das sitzen nur ein wenn was brauchen
aber dann auch wieder weg damit
sie führen den stil von angela merkel
denn sie jetzt eingehend beschrieben
haben
zurück auf ihre herkunft aus der ddr wo
ist da der zusammenhang näher man kann
es ja nicht eigentlich ableiten weil wir
in gauck ein anderes beispiel haben und
nicht nur im gange
das heißt je nachdem welche
persönlichkeit welchen bedingungen
ausgesetzt ist entsteht entweder eine
verschärfte sehnsucht nach freiheit wie
sie gott hat der sagt nie mehr und
freiheit nie mehr meinungsfreiheit und
so weiter und frau merkel hat im öfter
und ihre kollegen die mit ihr zb in der
aufbruchs bewegung waren haben das
geschildert sie hat öfter wahrgenommen
dass man besser mächtig als ohnmächtig
ist und es hat sie sich gemerkt und
gleichzeitig gesagt ich habe gelernt
zwischen den zeilen zu lesen
ich habe auch gelernt dass man besser
schweigt weil die leute die reden haben
sich oft und kopf und kragen geredet
das sind sicher dinge die hat sie in
diesem leise sein müssen gelernt und das
ist ja nichts negatives zunächst ist es
nur in dem moment ein problem wo man
selber dann immer weiter zu wenig
preisgibt von dem was man vorhat wo die
frage sich anschließt hast überhaupt was
vor oder fühlst du dich nur den jeweils
herrschenden trends schwimmst du mit um
mächtig zu bleiben und das hat nichts
mit ihrer herkunft zu tun
ich würde mal gerne eine bilanz ziehen
dessen was sie angela merkel davor
werfen also kritik an ihrem stil dass
sie zu wenig kommuniziert haben ja schon
viele vor ihnen geübt aber noch keiner
hat gesagt angela merkel arbeitet am
aufbau eines unrechtsstaat
ist es nicht einfach nicht los erzählt
auch in dem buch nicht so ist es nicht
insgesamt eine maßlose übertreibung die
sie da vorwerfen ich hatte vorhin
einiges von dem zitiert was sie gern die
vokabel nennen sie irgendwie am anfang
auf zitiert mit denen ich versuche zu
beschreiben dass ich meine also einmal
das verschwimmen der parteien grenzen so
dass immer mehr konsens druck entsteht
ein konsens den frau links fällt im
april dieses jahres und sie stammt ja
aus der ddr sehr hellsichtig beschrieben
hat als ein prozess den sie schon länger
beobachtet das heißt wenn du nicht mit
der mehrheit stimmt bisher isoliert
lesen sie mal die presse wir haben immer
häufiger jetzt auch artikel die sind
überschrieben weidmann hoffnungslos
isoliert da wird gar nicht mehr gefragt
ob der chef der bundesbank vielleicht
einfach nur seine pflicht tut und die
vertritt sonst wird gesagt du stehst
allein das ist nicht gut für dich
das heißt wir haben immer mehr alle
parteien entscheidungen mit der
begründung freunde jetzt müsst ihr alle
dafür sein
da ist oft nur die linke dagegen alle
anderen stimmen zu und wir haben einen
zentralistischen trennt den habe ich
schon beschrieben das heißt es wird in
regierung etwas entschieden und die
information wird so spät ist parlament
gereicht und auch oft so verschlüsselt
dass die parlamentarier sagen verdammt
noch mal
das darf keiner merken dass ich das
ganze nicht verstanden habe ich stimme
zu
ich bin bei alldem was sie merkel
vorwerfen eine rolle dass sie eine frau
ist
nein ich finde auch es spielt bei ihrem
regierungsstil keine rolle dass sie eine
frau ist spannend ist es nur in den
aller ersten start kapitel wo ja die
feigen jungs in den büschen hocken und
nicht wagen den schwarzen riesen vom
sockel zu stoßen und merkel erkennt ja
merkel erkennt dass es eilt und da gibt
es viele gespräche ich habe ja auch ein
gespräch zitiert das noch nirgendwo
zitierte wo sie gesagt hat wir müssen
uns jetzt so zieht er die ganze partei
mit runter
das heißt es ist nicht ihre
empfindlichkeit gegenüber der spenden
geschichte sondern es ist ihre
erkenntnis der platz muss frei wären und
sie tut dann das was keinem von den
männern tut und jahrelang waren die
männer so befangen
das überhaupt nicht gewagt haben merkel
in die parade zu fahren weil sie hatte
die tat getan sie hatte den burschen die
arbeit abgenommen
das ist sehr spannend weil hier ich habe
hier auch einen ddr psychiater zu wort
kommen lassen
der beschreibt wie diese vater
beziehungen er tatsächlich zu einer
besonderen entschlossenheit von testern
führen und wir dürfen nicht vergessen
angela merkel hat ja einen vater gehabt
der sie als kleines drei monate altes
kind mitgenommen hat in einen
totalitären staat und wir wissen dass
ihre beziehung zum vater zumindest eine
wenig kommentierte beziehung war und
wenn man die todesanzeige liest diese
verfasst hat wird das noch deutlicher
das heißt sie hat zweimal mächtige väter
hinter sich gelassen und das ist etwas
was natürlich frauen leben ist denn
keiner von den männern hat das gewagt
aber ich sage ab und zu auch was uns
verbindet ist folgendes wir haben beide
die arbeit der männer gemacht die die
männer nicht machen auch dieses hat kein
mann geschrieben und beide male hat die
frankfurter allgemeine die erste spur
dieses handelns veröffentlich gibt ihr
eine ganze reihe von gemeinsamkeiten
zwischen ihnen und angela merkel zum
beispiel die tatsache dass ihr aus dem
evangelisch nicht noch aus gibt es denn
noch mehr gemeinsamkeiten auch wenn sie
so kritik üben ich habe ja nein eine
ganze reihe freundliche gute gespräche
mit frau merkel gehabt nicht im
zusammenhang des buches aber in der zeit
davor
das heißt von merkel ist ein
freundlicher mensch sie ist übrigens
auch ein ein mensch ganz ohne wie soll
man das nennen ohne kapriolen ohne
irgendwelche skurrilen verhaltensweisen
wo man sich sagt moment mal musste er
reagieren
sie ist auf eine weise normal und
unbefangen wenn man mit ihr spricht
wobei die unbefangenheit sicher auch
eine täuschung sein kann deine tasche
die das gegenüber sich zurecht legt aber
ich sage ihnen mal ein beispiel sie hat
mir geschildert wie es für sie war
nachdem sie besucht worden war von einem
sehr kritischen helmut schmidt und dann
sagte sie zu mir hat sich in den raum
kam ist schwarzer sofa der helmut
schmidt gesessen und er hat mir die
ganze zeit nur negatives über
deutschlands zukunft erzählt ich mag
mich da gar nicht mehr hinsetzen
es sind ganz blass als absoluten absolut
es war eine unbefangene äußerung ja dass
sowas konnte er nicht irgendwie
strategische bedeutung haben
das heißt sie ist und so habe ich sie
auch am anfang in ihrem ersten abend
erlebt sie ist von einer in gänsefüßchen
naivität gegenüber vielen fakten die sie
noch nicht kennt zum beispiel als als
ministerin für frauen und familie
wo sieht es im wilden feminismus gar
nicht verstand und haben viele ddr
frauen nicht verstanden gesagt womit
vertreibt ihr euch denn die zeit bei uns
sagt freya klier kam der druck von oben
und der traf alle und das heißt wir
waren verbunden männer und frauen und
sie haben ja auch viel ähnlichere berufe
gehabt die männer und die frauen
das heißt das erstarken von frauen ist
ein ddr phänomen und zwar ohne den umweg
über den feminismus
sie haben sich ihr ganzes leben für die
emanzipation der frauen eingesetzt haben
gekämpft für frauen in
führungspositionen
eigentlich müssten sie sich doch freuen
dass wir eine kanzlerin haben die so
macht bewusst ist und die macht so
entschlossen in die hand nimmt
ja ich glaube ich habe geschildert an
welchen stellen ich meine dass der
gebrauch denn sie von der macht macht
unter umständen spielregeln verletzt die
wir als demokraten aller achten sollten
und dient dann verfassung stehen
also ich sage ja nie vom kindergarten in
den aufsichtsrat
ich sage also nie frauen weil sie frauen
sind auf vier positionen bringen sondern
sie ist ich würde sogar zögern zu sagen
als frau kanzlerin geworden
nein sie ist kanzlerin geworden weil sie
es entschiedener wollte als alle männer
um sie herum
das ist der punkt es ist nicht so
wichtig ob sie eine frau ist sondern
ihre games still bis diskutiert werden
unabhängig davon
das war heute im dialog mit gertrud
höhler herzlichen dank